hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my Cersei valonqar prophecy video
there's evidence for a couple different
people being the valonqar so I'll
explain what the prophecy is and who I
think it is just careful for spoilers
for everything that's happened on the
show so far there is a new round of the
game of Thrones giveaway going on now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's for an HBO now gift
certificate be sure to click that Bell
to enable alerts so that you don't miss
anything during the break so as a child
Cersei visited Maggie the frock and
asked her three questions one of those
answers was the prophecy of the valonqar
but the TV show only showed part of that
tell me my future or I'll have your two
boring eyes gouged out of your head oh
yes you'll be queen for a time and comes
another
younger more beautiful to cast you down
and take all you all dear well the King
and I have children know the king will
have 20 children and you will have three
that doesn't make sense
gold will be their crowns cold shrouds
so you can see how the TV show
wanted to highlight how Cersei would
lose all her children in how another
younger more beautiful person would come
along to take her throne talking about
Margaery Tyrell but another part of
Maggie's prophecy the valonqar was left
out probably because they wanted to do
it later on the show and it didn't
really have anything to do with what was
happening during season five so the full
prophecy goes like this
Cersei asks her will the King and I have
children in Maggie answers
oh I six and ten for him talking about
all of Robert's bastards he had a lot of
children three for you talking about
search these children gold shall be
their crowns and gold shall be their
shrouds talking about how they'd wind up
dying then she goes on and says and when
your tears have drowned you the valonqar
shall wrap his hands about your pale
white throat and choke the life from you
so valonqar is high Valyrian for a
younger brother so a lot of people read
this and they say okay her younger
brother Tyrion is going to kill her
eventually because of scenes like this I
will hurt you for this
the day will come when you think you're
safe and happy and your joy will turn to
ashes in your mouth
and you will know the debt is paid get
it out
so just taken at face value Tyrion has
always been the leading candidate for
the valonqar he is their younger brother
Jaime and Cersei are twins but what has
been changing in the last couple of
seasons on the TV show Jaime has slowly
been becoming a good person even though
he is still very much connected to
Cersei like it seems like he might break
from her influence he feels like he
loves her he has a duty to her but his
heart is pulled - Brienne her good
influence has slowly been inspiring him
to do better and better things he's
trying to do good but Godfather style
Cersei has been pulling him back in and
now that she's Queen she's more powerful
than ever so even though we're getting
ready for all-out war in the Seven
Kingdoms between the forces of the crown
Cersei
Daenerys his forces in Jon Snow's forces
there's still a lot of Jaime when he was
at Riverrun
that's starting to slowly realize that
this is all madness
so when Yuri watch the Riverrun scenes
you can see that he could have just rode
in with his soldiers killed everyone in
taken the castle but he actually tried
to reason with everyone he tried to
reason with the blackfish which was a
terrible idea you can't reason with the
blackfish but Jaime still tried he's all
about trying to keep his word
his honor because everybody says that he
has none because he's the Kingslayer
it's been this long think of all he's
been through he is still in the minds of
people like the blackfish just the
Kingslayer with no honor what does the
word of a Kingslayer mean it means zero
you have no honor you clearly have no
intention of saving your men's lives why
did you come treat with me sieges a doll
and I wanted to see you in person get
the measure of you well now you have
I'm disappointed
[Music]
so that bugs the hell out of Jamie he is
trying to be honorable he wants to do
good things but he's forced to do the
will of Cersei for now so when you start
thinking about his reaction to Cersei at
the end of the season slowly becoming
more and more afraid of her the things
that she's willing to do the horrified
look on his face when he sees the great
Sept blow up now at this point in the
story the TV shows changed the book plot
for these characters quite a bit Jamie's
not at King's Landing to witness this
he's already sworn off Cersei at this
point in the books they haven't had sex
since they did in the Sept over
Joffrey's dead body which was traumatic
enough but that was basically the last
time they were ever together as man and
woman after that Jaime effectively
abandoned her at least emotionally so
what it seems like the show has been
teasing is that Cersei is slowly going
mad queen in that history will repeat
itself
for Jaime he will realize that she needs
to be stopped before she can kill
everyone and he will become the queen
Slayer just like he was the Kingslayer
Bernal where's my sister but then you
say the valonqar prophecy is all about
the little brother Tyrion sir little
brother but one of the really important
hidden points is that even though
they're twins
Cersei was born first so even though
they're born at the same time
Jaime is the younger brother by a couple
minutes so by the prophecy he can still
be the valonqar in what a twist for his
character that would be it would totally
be in keeping with the arc that he is on
an even better example is when he's
talking to Walder Frey in Walder Frey is
just chuckling at the idea that they're
both kingslayer's everybody hates them
and this is such a wonderful thing like
they're so awesome that they have this
in common in Jaime recoils in disgust at
the idea that they share anything in
common it doesn't matter here we are now
two kings lands we know what it's like
to have them grubbles or our faces and
snicker behind up
Bax we don't mind doing fear is a Maoist
thing and I know a lot of people would
still like to see Tyrion kill Cersei but
it also seems just like Jaime Tyrion has
been growing up himself - he hasn't been
whoring as much he hasn't been getting
drunk as much we still see him drinking
but we don't see him get blackout drunk
and now that he's handed the Queen to
Daenerys he has so much responsibility
he just has to go into hardcore
analytical mode with Varys to plan what
they're going to be doing and how
they're going to win the Iron Throne and
get rid of Cersei but through all the
craziness in Mereen when he was trying
to hold the city together while Daenerys
was away it seemed like he really cared
about the people so even though he does
want to get rid of Cersei he doesn't
want to just kill everybody on sight so
he is not the same Tyrion of this moment
here this actually this line here where
he says your joy will turn to ashes in
your mouth that was from season 2
episode 8 so that's actually a long time
ago so you guys can let me know who do
you think the valonqar is and do you
think that the TV show is going to do
that but there are a couple alternate
valonqar prophecy theories just because
little brother could be a more broad
description of a little brother to
someone else not necessarily Circe's
little brother so even though I do think
that it's talking about Jaime they could
be talking about Aegon Targaryen from
the books they could be talking about
Gendry who is one of the younger
brothers of the other bastards of Robert
Baratheon but it could also you know
surprise twist Valyrian is
gender-neutral when it comes to pronouns
so little brother could just mean little
sibling as in little sister as well like
Daenerys but I don't see Daenerys like
throttling Cersei that would actually be
a pretty funny sight because Daenerys is
pretty small in speaking of size
difference you know little brother even
though I don't think this is the case
Sandor Clegane the Hound is the little
brother so that would actually be a
little bit more fun to see him throttle
Cersei but Jamie still seems like the
best pick but there are a couple other
fun alternatives so let me know who is
your alternate pick who do you think
would have the most satisfying time
killing Cersei and if you want to
request another theory or a prophecy
video from me just let me know in the
comments really that's what the off
season
for till we wait for it to come back
talk about all the crazy prophecies and
theories but I will say congratulations
to this week's giveaway winner Andrew
Wright you win an HBO now gift
certificate so be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details sophie
turner was talking about how not all of
the main characters are going to make it
out of season 7 alive so my next game of
Thrones bonus video is probably going to
be death predictions for the most likely
candidates all the way down to least
likely like of the body of main
characters they could kill off in season
7 little fingers close to the top of the
list bottom of the list would be people
like Daenerys Jon Snow so I'll do a
bonus video for that next Sunday
later tonight there's a fast and furious
trailer posting I'll do a video for that
and then the Walking Dead finale so
whole bunch of stuff happening it's
gonna be a lot of fun well you guys wait
for that to post you can click here to
rewatch that season 7 teaser they drop
and you can click here to rewatch those
spider-man homecoming trailers thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
Oh